Mary here the game spot news update some  smoke and hot new screenshots of Laura  in a bikini in the freezing weather have  just been released just kidding she's in  a parka let's take a look these shots  from rise of the Tomb Raider show Lara  scaling ice walls fighting a bear in the  snow exploring ice caves enjoying views  of snow-covered mountains and also  looking at a helicopter in a place that  doesn't seem to have any ice at all  what's up with that rise of the Tomb  Raider will take Lara to the icy wilds  of Siberia following her last adventure  from the previous game Tomb Raider this  game will feature a day and night cycle  dynamic weather and varying animals to  fight this game launches this holiday  exclusively for xbox one and 360  although it might come to other  platforms at a later date check out the  full resolution screen shots over at  gamespot com / news